Los tres amigos reunidos el Primer
Ministro de Canadá Justin trudeo el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
de México Andrés Manuel López Obrador
entregaron las conclusiones de su primer
encuentro en la Ciudad de México donde
abordar un temas de migración cambio
climático y narcotráfico baiden destacó
la importancia de la relación trilateral
para atender estos asuntos
con estos aliados y socios más cercanos
ninguno es más cercano que México y
Canadá para asumir los mayores desafíos
que enfrenta la región francamente
también el mundo porque ya no puede
haber ninguna duda ninguna en el mundo
interconectado de hoy no podemos
encerrarnos en muros precisamente López
Obrador informó que lograron acuerdos
migratorios y celebró las políticas
canadienses que ya le han permitido a
25.000 mexicanos trabajar en su
territorio a su vez destacó que el
presidente estadounidense no haya
construido ni un metro del muro
fronterizo dicho y lo repito ahora
usted es el primer presidente de Estados
Unidos en mucho tiempo
que no ha construido ni un metro de muro
Y eso
se lo agradecemos
aunque no les guste
a los
conservadores
el presidente mexicano anunció además la
creación de un comité conjunto en
Norteamérica para la sustitución de
importaciones también
la integración económica y comercial
como ya lo expresé
dejando atrás el intervencionismo
hegemónico frente al desafío del cambio
climático el Primer Ministro canadiense
celebró que sus homólogos prometieron
cumplir con los compromisos del acuerdo
de París debemos tomar partido en la
acción climática los gobiernos y los
sectores privados deben trabajar
conjuntamente para cumplir los objetivos
climáticos de 2030 además resaltó que
los tres jefes de estado de Norteamérica
se comprometieron a proteger los
derechos de las mujeres y niñas
especialmente de las indígenas de sus
países
[Música]